they don't know what to do and it's like
is that dip
uh nicotine you want something no no no
no i dipped for a long time
like this is like these are nicotine
pouches so it's like uh they're
tobacco-free were you a dipper or never
neither neither i listen to a podcast on
how nicotine
uh helps with like if you've suffered
brain trauma or
cpt yeah they've seen like as you get
older
the one thing that they've seen in
smokers it's not because the
cigarettes but it's nicotine from
cigarettes one thing they all have in
common is there
something like 90 percent less likely to
have dementia because the nicotine what
it does for your brain is insane yeah so
i was like man how can i get nicotine i
saw spray
then i saw these tobacco-free uh pouches
i'll try those i don't know i feel
smarter let me ask you something
i need to know something i can't
remember a single name off any show
like an eye someone has to i just go
well the guy and then the girl like
nate was i don't know what that is
character names never
i'm bad with ufc names unless it's a
major star i'm bad with it
it's like uh i don't like my brain just
like not important
you dude we're doing our best you don't
need to remember that
i'm the same way i think mine is weed
induced
but but then also like it's like my
brain must be okay because
if if tonight you asked me to do an hour
of material i can remember my different
material
i don't write it down your brain tells
you what's important my brain goes yeah
dude
no we got enough going on you have it
you don't need to know the name of
[ __ ]
the cast members on yellowstone no yeah
you're good your
your brain makes the noise that whitney
does at the beginning of our podcast bob
i'm terrible with names but if you're
asking me
what was the name of the person or you
know you don't absolutely terrible with
lyrics for songs ah the worst i make
them up
i do my girl goes my cousin blah blah
blast coming over
i go have i met her she goes are you
[ __ ] me
we've been together for six you you've
met her multiple times i go
what's her name and then i go what's her
husband's name she's like
unbelievable you went on a bike ride
with that guy i'm like
yeah i didn't know his name yeah i
called him hey yeah yeah
yeah you hear that she goes you're the
worst i'm like no no you gotta remember
my brain only stores so much
so my brain goes you really don't need
to know that bibi
did you tell her i can either remember
your cousin's name or yours yeah
you pick your choice i have one spot
left do you
do you i have dying to know this because
i was watching some
ufc over the weekend some highlight some
clips sure when you're
getting when you're in the ring or after
the ring after getting hit
that many times is that and immediately
after does that ever enter i hope
there's no permanent
not well especially when i was fighting
like ct and brain trauma
wasn't really even conversation like it
wasn't
it was like oh you got your bell rung
like you're fine that was the term when
i was going like oh you got your bell
rung like i remember
in football they would put me in on
certain plays just to see me collide
with this guy brian ew who
played for the chicago bears and was the
captain of our team but it was called
uh a 94 power power
power toss so the fullback would just
run as fast can
and the outside linebacker be there and
would just it'd be it'd be like two
battering rams
but the entire team and coaches would
stop because everyone would look at the
play
the f give away the play so the guy's
like oh here we go
and the whole team was just watch i
remember just like us bashing heads as
far as we can
every week twice a week and now i think
i'm like what the [ __ ] were we doing let
me ask you something and then in
fighting it's like
oh you got your bell wrong just you know
just lay low like drink water
what's happening in the ring when you
get your bell round you don't think
about it
but aren't you trying to regain your
senses or you
yeah but you're like getting training
yeah it's like your survival like you
ought to come back you're just trying to
buy
time shake off the cobwebs as they call
it like you're just trying to
maneuver so you don't get hit again it's
still i remember it wasn't
i remember i would be in the ring and
bruce buffer would announce my name
or he'd he'd announce somebody like
let's say he announced matt madrone's
name first
and they announced mine and as he
announced my name i would have my head
go what the [ __ ] am i doing
as he's shouting in my face i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing
what am i doing i i it's not good it
baffles me
that if i knew this morning i'm getting
up and going to work
and someone's gonna punch me in the face
multiple times
at my job it's the toughest job in the
world well
how many times do boxers get hit in the
face
in a fight well i mean that's the point
right i mean hundreds
that's like saying how often does
microphones get wet that's what i'm
saying like
that is your job to and i people i know
there are a lot of people
like this [ __ ] that's not your job
either [ __ ] okay you know what i
mean so you call me a [ __ ] all you want
the other thing that you know the the
way people should have more respect for
fighters is like
let's say you're a guy like uh somebody
coming up you can name anyone
but let's say you beat the number eight
guy in the world
let's say you're ranked number 10 you
beat the number eight guy in the world
and you go on vacation you know
that as soon as you get back there's
this monster right number six that
they're going to pair you up with and
you know how [ __ ] tough he is
and be like oh just relax take it easy
but you just it's like
it's like if you got bullied at school
and you know the next day you got to see
that bully
it's that all the time for me it was
it was like all the time just like ah
you just have that pit in your stomach
you're like oh god he's so cute
and then and then you beat him and then
you beat him you beat the number six guy
well you know the number five guy
you know the number four guy you're
looking through the list just like
wow does anybody ever and so
one of the reasons i like sitting down
with you is i'm gonna ask a lot of
layman's questions
no please that other people would never
ask does anybody this is going to sound
dumb and maybe it's just the little
brother in me
thinking about how to win fights yeah
but does anybody ever decide all right
i'm not showering for a week i'm not
brushing my teeth and i'm not watching
it wouldn't it matter
wouldn't matter wouldn't matter in there
now it's a lot you like that sketching
was like [ __ ] and then you just beat the
[ __ ] out of them
but so so that doesn't matter that that
doesn't if someone came in it was like i
no i remember the only time like i
remember when i was fighting crow cop i
was like god he smells funny
and i was like and then this is wall my
nose is broken
we're in the middle it's the biggest
fight in my career it's in uh
new jersey sold out crowd jon jones
fighting shogun for his first world
title
biggest fight in my life he's a legend i
remember my nose is shattered i'm
bleeding everywhere
and we're there and the crowd's like
chanting whatever
thinking god he smells funny and then i
swear to god i'm going
i'm thinking look at this
i'm thinking god he smells funny and
then and in my head i go
well he's probably croatian so it's just
it's just it's just different you know
like does he
maybe he thinks i smell funny and then
it could douche elbow on there
all right let's stop thinking about that
listen when i get off stage with the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son